What is hell? in this video we're gonna
look at seven facts about Hell. Hi I'm
pastor Mark Finley and for the last 50
years I've traveled the world standing
on some of the great platforms of the
world speaking to thousands of people on
the subject of God's love and the fires
of hell. What does the Bible teach about
Hell? We're going to look at seven facts
that you probably don't know about Hell.
The first thing that we want to look at
is this that God does not delight in
destroying people. God is a God of
love. In first John chapter 4 verse 8 the
Bible says God is love in Jeremiah
chapter 31 verse 3 the Bible says that
with bands of love have I drawn you can
you picture in your mind a loving God
burning people in hell for millions and
millions and millions of years if indeed
God is omniscient that means he knows
everything and he does and if indeed God
is omnipresent
that means he's present through his
spirit everywhere and he is would that
then not mean that if hell was a place
that was burning through the endless
ages ceaselessly God would have a
knowledge of that and that God would
also be present there through his spirit
if he's omnipresent you see will we
someday be in heaven flying over a
certain place in heaven and hear some
screams and we say to an angel what's
that oh that's people burning in hell
well or will we be with God one day and
smell some smoke coming up and say
what's that oh that's that's the flames
of hell
you see if he'll continues to exist for
millions and millions of years how do
you harmonize that with the character of
God a character of love wouldn't God
want to do away with evil forever you
see my mind can understand
that God has to deal with evil my mind
can understand that evil will be
eradicated from the universe because if
it wasn't it would just simply spring up
and continue to smolder but it would be
difficult for me to understand how a
loving God can burn people forever and
ever and ever and ever and ever in the
flames I mean we look at some despite ik
rulers who tortured their people
despotic rulers who killed millions of
people and we see that throughout
history is God no better than that
certainly he is in the book of Peter 2nd
Peter chapter 3 verse 9 the Bible speaks
about this heart of this loving God and
it says the Lord is not slack concerning
his promise as some men count slackness
but is long-suffering toward us not
willing that any should perish but that
all should come to repentance
here's fact number one God is a God of
love and he does not desire any human
being to perish the longing of God's
heart is to save every human being and
he's done everything he can and is doing
everything he can to save the whole
human race the cross of Calvary is
enough to save you
his righteousness is enough to save you
his grace is enough to save you his love
is enough to save you now here's the
second fact the bible does not teach
that the wicked the unsaved will be
burning in hell for trillions of years
in fact it does teach that they'll be
consumed and burned up go on forever you
say it's that true where do you find
that in the Bible let me read it to you
Malachi chapter 4 and you know you never
build a Bible teaching on one text so
let me give you a number of text here's
Malachi chapter 4 verse 1 behold the day
is coming burning like an oven so in
other words the day is not here Hales
not
hot spot in the center of the earth the
day is coming and all the proud yes and
all that do wickedly will be stubble the
day is coming
Malachi 4 verse 1 that will burn them up
so the Bible says they'll be burned up
they'll be consumed they'll be gone
forever verse 2 but to you who fear my
name the son of righteous will arise
with healing in his wings and notice
what scripture says for they will be
ashes under the soles of your feet ashes
so the Bible says that the wicked will
be consumed they'll be burned up they
will be as stubble the Bible says
they'll be left neither root nor branch
they'll be ashes under the soles of your
feet totally destroyed Psalm 37 verse 10
you find this throughout the Bible this
is not someone text hidden hidden
obscurely in some biblical passage this
is the common teaching of scripture some
37 and we're looking there at verse 10
for yet a little while and the wicked
shall be no more
indeed you look diligently for his place
but it shall be no more so the wicked
will be what no more but if we look at
verse 20 but the wicked shall perish the
enemies of the Lord like the splendor of
the meadows shall vanish into smoke they
shall vanish away
so here's fact number two remember what
fact number one is you got that God is a
God of love he wants to save all
humanity fact number two the wicked will
be burned up they'll be consumed they'll
be gone forever they will be ashes under
our feet see my mind could never
comprehend a God of love burning and
tormenting people for millions of years
but I could comprehend that God gives
people a chance to live he moves upon
their life with His Holy Spirit he does
everything he can to save them but if
they reject his love if they spurn his
grace that the fiery presence of our
Lord
zooms them as he returns and if they're
alive they're they're consumed with the
brightness of his coming the Bible says
and the Bible talks also about a period
called a thousand years at the end of
that thousand year period that the
wicked are resurrected again during the
thousand years that the righteous are in
heaven because when Jesus comes at the
beginning of that period called the
thousand years the righteous dead are
resurrected the righteous living ascend
to heaven with Christ they reign with
Christ on Thrones for a thousand years
this is revelation 20 verse 1 to 12 you
can read it there and at the end of the
thousand years the holy city descends at
the beginning of the thousand years the
wicked living are destroyed with the
brightness of Christ's coming the wicked
dead remain in their graves but at the
end of the thousand years the holy city
descends the wicked rush up to take that
city we'll study a little bit more about
that further on in our video and they're
destroyed with the brightness of
Christ's coming they're gone and out of
the ashes of an old world God makes a
new world now the Bible teaches and
here's our third fact fact number one
God is love wants to save all humanity
fact number two the wicked are burned up
they're consumed here's fact number
three everlasting punishment now watch
this one is not everlasting punishing a
lot of people make that mistake they
think everlasting punishment is
everlasting punishing Matthew chapter 25
verse 46 somebody says well there's the
text it says everlasting punishment well
let's take a look at it does it say
everlasting punishing so look Matthew 25
verse 46 here we have it the scripture
says these that's the wicked will go
away into everlasting punishment but the
righteous into eternal life everlasting
punishment is one punishment that is
everlasting in other words that
punishment the fact that the wicked are
consumed or burned up lasts forever it
never has to be repeated everlasting
punishing would be
a continued state of punishment where
they would be burning continually the
bible does not say that but somebody
says the bible does say they were burned
with an eternal fire how can you say
that it doesn't last ceaselessly if
they're burned with an eternal fire well
let's turn in our Bibles and discover
what that means we're gonna go to the
book of Jude it's a little tiny book
before the book of Revelation try to
discover a little bit about this eternal
fire the Bible teaches in Jude chapter 7
as Sodom and Gomorrah and the cities
around them in a similar matter now you
know I was teaching once about this
subject and read about Sodom and
Gomorrah and somebody said who are they
two twin sisters now they're not two
twin sisters Sodom and Gomorrah of
course are two wicked cities in the Old
Testament as Sodom and Gomorrah and the
cities around them in a similar manner
to these having given themselves over to
sexual immorality going after strange
flesh are set forth as an example
suffering the Vengeance of eternal fire
now follow me closely Sodom and Gomorrah
were two wicked cities filled with
immorality crime and violence they are
an example of the wickedness the
corruption of the world at endtime they
were burned with an eternal fire here's
my question are Sodom and Gomorrah these
two wicked cities of millenniums ago are
they still burning today obviously
they're not they're destroyed they are
archaeologists have excavated in an area
they believe may have been started and
Gomorrah in the area the Dead Sea so
what then is an eternal fire if the
eternal fire does not burn eternally
it's a fire whose consequences are
eternal Sodom and Gomorrah never needed
to be burned again
now the Bible describes this in 2nd
Peter it talks about Sodom and Gomorrah
it talks about the fire that burned them
and it helps us to understand very
clearly what an eternal fire is 2nd
Peter chapter 2 the
importance in studying the Bible is
letting the Bible interpret itself Sodom
and Gomorrah were burned with an eternal
fire what does an eternal fire do what
are the effects of an eternal fire
second Peter chapter 2 and we're going
to look there at verses 4 5 & 6 for if
God did not spare the angels that sinned
but cast them down to hell that's the
word is Taurus it means a place of
darkness the Greek word there is
darkness cast into the outer areas of
darkness it says it delivered them into
chains of Darkness to be reserved for
judgment so they weren't cast into some
burning place but the devil and as evil
angels were reserved for judgment if
something is reserved it's not currently
in use they were reserved for judgment
did not spare the ancient world but
saved Noah one of eight people a
preacher of righteousness bringing in
the flood on the world of the ungodly
now verse 6 and turning the cities of
Sodom and Gomorrah into ashes condemned
them to destruction and making them an
example to those who afterward would
live ungodly so the cities of Sodom and
Gomorrah were burned in an eternal fire
but the eternal fire burned them
consumed them into ashes what's an
eternal fire an eternal fire is a fire
that does not need to be repeated it's
one whose effects or the consequences of
that fire are eternal in this case of
sodom and gomorrah an eternal fire
turned those cities into ashes someone
asked me the question what about the
Bible text that says the fire won't be
quenched what does that mean to be
quenched means to be put out the fires
of hell cannot be put out by any human
hands because those fires come down from
God out of heaven 2 totally consumed the
wicked so there's no way that human
beings can quench them they burn
themselves out now notice how the Bible
use
the term unquenchable fire we're gonna
read in Matthew chapter 3 verse 11 and
12 we're looking there Matthew 3 verse
11 and 12 it says here John the Baptist
I indeed baptize you with water unto
repentance but he was coming after me
that's mightier than I whose sandals I'm
not worthy to carry verse 12 his
winnowing fan is in his hand he will
thoroughly purge his threshing floor and
gather his wheat into the barn but he
will burn up the chaff with unquenchable
fire now somebody says there it is it's
unquenchable fire what is an
unquenchable fire what is a fire that
can't be quenched look at Jeremiah 17
the Bible talks about Jerusalem and when
Jerusalem was burned it says it was
burned with an in quench evil fire
Jeremiah 17 and we're looking there at
verses 19 to 27 and the Bible points
this out it talks about the Prophet
Jeremiah prophesying against Jerusalem
because of its disobedience to God and
as it does it says verse 27 it shall be
if you'll not heed me to hallow the
sabbath such as not carrying a burden
when entering the gates of Jerusalem on
the sabbath day then i will kindle a
fire in its gates and it shall devour
the palaces of Jerusalem now listen to
this it shall not be quenched so here is
Jerusalem still burning tonight it is
not see an unquenchable fire the Romans
came down in AD 70 they burned the
temple at Jerusalem they burned to the
City of Jerusalem and attack that city
terrible devastation but the
unquenchable fire was a fire that no
human hands could put out here's three
facts so far what are they do you have
them God is a God of the law he wants to
save every human being secondly God
Himself says that sin us will be burned
up they'll be consumed to ashes thirdly
everlasting punishment or unquenchable
fire is a fire that comes from heaven in
the fiery presence of God at the end of
that thousand year period that can never
be put out by human hands now is hell
some hot spot burning in the center of
the earth tonight certainly not second
Peter 2 verse 4 says what that they
would be easy evil angels would be
reserved under the day of judgment
revelation 20 verse 9 tells us that the
wicked will be destroyed
at the end of the thousand years and out
of the ashes of this old world God will
create a new world
here's revelation 20 and verse 9 and
onward the Bible puts it this way now in
the thousand years I'll go back to verse
7 when the thousand years have expired
that's finished Satan's released out of
his prison Satan and the evil angels
have been bound to earth you can read
that in Revelation 21 to 5 they go out
to deceive the nations who've been
resurrected now from the dead that's the
wicked because in Revelation 20 verse 5
it says the rest of the Dead did not
live till the thousand years are
finished that's the wicked they're
resurrected at the end of the thousand
years they go up on the breadth of the
earth surround the camp of the Saints
and fire comes down from God out of
heaven and devoured them now the Bible
is very plain fire comes down from God
out of heaven and devoured them so the
fires of hell do not originate in the
earth the Bible says in Hebrews 12 verse
29 our God is a consuming fire so God's
character of love and grace and
righteousness draws to himself the
righteous but that glorious light of his
character is so all-consuming that the
wicked are destroyed by its glorious
brightness it's like if you take clay a
clay pot and you put it under intense
fire it hardens
but you put wax under that fire and it
melts so sin
is combustible material in the sight of
God and so sinners who cling to sin fire
comes down from God out of here they
can't stand the glory of his presence
they can't stand the righteousness of
his character and that's in which
they've embraced is consumed and through
the glory of God's presence so the
fourth point is this the fires of hell
do not originate in the center of the
earth they originate they come down from
heaven and it's the the righteousness of
Christ the glory of Christ consumed sin
wherever it's found and if sin is found
in them they're consumed by that
righteousness now here's the fifth point
about it
Satan will be destroyed forever this is
the fact that most people don't know
Satan's not going to be living in Hell
forever his evil angels are not going to
be there did you know that hell is going
to be burn itself out that Satan is
gonna be consumed forever you say
where's that in the Bible let me show
you
Ezekiel chapter 28 I mean Satan is not
gonna live forever he does not have
eternal life he's gonna be consumed his
father's will be consumed look speaking
about Satan speaking about the evil one
in Ezekiel chapter 28 it says you were
the seal of perfection you were full of
wisdom verse 12 you were in the Eden the
garden of God this is Satan it says you
were perfect in your ways from the day
you were created until iniquity or sin
rebellion was founded in you verse 17
your heart was lifted up because of your
beauty you corrupted your wisdom but
what happens to him notice it says you
defiled the sanctuaries by the multitude
of your iniquities therefore I brought
fire in your midst it devoured you it
turns you into ashes upon the earth in
the sight of all who saw you all who
knew you among the peoples were
astonished you become a horror and
you'll be no more forever so Satan will
be no more forever now this is good news
sin will be destroyed wickedness will be
destroyed filthiness will be destroyed
unholiness will be destroyed
and unrighteousness will be destroyed so
every vestige of sin is gonna be gone
forever
this fact is an amazing fact about Hell
Satan is destroyed forever the fires of
hell will burn out
Isaiah 47 verse 14
Isaiah 47 and verse 14 the fires of hell
will burn out it's not going to be let
there to go go on ceaselessly Isaiah 47
verse 14 behold they shall be as stubble
the fire shall burn them they shall not
deliver themselves from the power of the
flame it shall not be a coal to be
warmed at nor a fire to sit before Wow
he'll be burned to ashes but there won't
be a coal to sit before that won't even
be according to this Bible passage it
there won't even be a fire to sit at or
a coal to be worn by why it's gone
totally going Satan is burned up and
consumed his angels are consumed the
wicked are consumed the fires of hell go
out somebody says but but Pastor Mark
there is a Bible passage that's it talks
about forever and ever
what about that passage how do you
explain that you know we've looked at
multiple passages that talk about the
wicked being consumed Psalm 37 verse 10
2013 onward the wicked being burned to
ashes Malachi chapter four one two three
we've looked about the fact that the
wicked are reserved unto judgement
devil is going to be burned up isaiah 47
Obadiah 16 says that the the wicked will
be as though they've not been in other
words they're consumed we've seen that
the whole idea of ever burning hell is
inconsistent with the character of God
so you never take one text that you
don't fully understand and throw out
fifty a hundred texts that are very very
clear so I want to look at the text
forever and ever very clearly and see
the meaning of that text and then let
the Bible explain itself the passage
that you're talking about on forever and
ever is
halation chapter 20 and it's there in
verse 10 now notice what has happened
just before that passage in Revelation
20 verse 9 it says that the wicked went
up on the breadth of the earth and
surrounded the camp of the Saints in the
beloved city and the fire came down from
God out of heaven and devoured them so
that's very plain
they are devoured they're destroyed the
Bible says they perish the Bible says
like smoke they consume away there turn
to ashes then it says the devil that
deceived them was cast into the lake of
fire
that's this fiery earth at the end of
time before God creates a new heaven and
a new earth and brimstone where the
beast and the false prophet are and
they'll be tormented day and night
forever and ever
what does that mean they'll be tormented
day and night forever and ever
have you ever heard of the word eons or
Aeons it's an interesting Greek
expression they're a on totosai onnum
Aeon means age totus means total so
until it could be translated until the
end of the age so they're burned up
until the end of the age what does that
mean Revelation chapter 20 ends the
thousand years that ends the earth age
revelation 21 John says I saw a new
heaven and a new earth coming down from
God out of heaven so the wicked are
burned up until the end of the earth age
until the end of the age that's the
literal translation but there's a new
heavens and a new earth that comes down
where wickedness is gone forever the
Bible does not use the expression
forever and ever as endless existence in
fact in Exodus chapter 21 there and
Exodus 21 verse 6 it talks about a slave
and it talks about the mark in the ear
of the slave and it's very fascinating
when you look at Exodus 21 verse 6
because it says the slave look Exodus 21
verse 6 then it says that the slave will
have his ear pierced and he'll serve his
master
forever does that mean there'll be
slavery in heaven and that the masters
will have domination over the slaves not
a bit of it the word forever simply
means until the end of the age he would
he would serve his master as long as he
lived in this life in fact the Bible
does use the term
forever as as long as one can live in
that particular environment
now here the Bible of course is not in
any way condoning slavery
it is simply stating the fact that the
whole in the air symbolized that this
slave would be responsible to his master
the Bible speaks about the dignity and
the worth of every human being but here
in the book of Samuel for example and
you look at 1st Samuel chapter 1 and
here in in Samuel the Bible talks about
Samuel and it says regarding him that
Samuel would go up to the temple of the
Lord and there in that temple he would
serve the Lord forever
his mother he remember brought him up at
a very young age and we're looking at
1st Samuel Chapter 1 and Hannah brings
Samuel up to the temple first Samuel
chapter 1 verse 22 but Hannah did not go
up for she said to her husband I'll not
go up until the child is weaned then
I'll take him that he may appear before
the Lord and remain there forever so
Samuel would go up before the Lord
forever now verse 28 defines how long
that is and verse 28 says therefore I
have lent him to the Lord as long as he
lives he'll be lent to the Lord so
forever in this case was as long as
Samuel would live in the Bible forever
is as long as you can live in that
environment the slave would serve his
master forever as long as he lived in
that environment Sam will be up in the
temple forever as long as he could live
in that environment fire comes down from
God out of heaven and devoured them
revelation 20 they're consumed forever
forever means as long as they could live
there in that environment the fires of
hell they live and are consumed and are
burned up until the end of the age until
in fact the new world comes and the holy
city comes down and descends upon them
so forth
the righteous live forever what does
that mean as long as they can live in
the environment of heaven and how long
can they live their unceasing existence
the wicked cannot exist in the fires of
hell in unceasing existence therefore
the fire consumes them therefore the
fire burns them up the last fact about
hell is this God does not do anything
halfway
he doesn't roast sinners in Hell and
keep them in torment he creates a new
heaven and a new earth
even when Hell itself is gone I want you
to look there at second Peter we're
gonna look at 2nd Peter and we're gonna
look at Revelation chapter 21 2nd Peter
in Revelation chapter 21 here we find in
2nd Peter chapter 3 the Bible says
nevertheless we according to his promise
look for a new heavens and a new earth
in which righteousness dwells hell will
be gone forever Satan will be gone
forever there's a new heavens and a new
earth coming a loving God has done
everything he can to redeem and win
human beings but there's a new day
coming and look at what the Bible says
this passage in Revelation chapter 21
would not be true if indeed people were
burning in hell for trillions of years
Revelation 21 verse 4 they're not though
the Bible says God's going to wipe away
every tear from our eyes there'll be no
more death nor sorrow nor crying
there'll be no more pain for the former
things have passed away God says I'll
make everything new and God says it is
done is done
sickness suffering and heartache are
over it has done pain sickness disease
are over it is done
death has done away with forever
and we live with Christ - the ceaseless
ages of eternity this is God's plan for
you you see every one of us have one of
two choices the choice of eternal life
for the choice of eternal loss the
choice of living with Christ forever but
the choice of being gone forever the
pain of Hell is incalculable for this
reason in those last lingering moments
when people are being consumed in the
flames and burned to ashes they know
that they could have lived forever but
it's over over over forever and they
have that consciousness the Bible talks
about it as weeping and gnashing of
teeth they have that consciousness I
could have lived but I'm gone separated
from the presence of the God forever
gone that need not be your experienced
friend I don't know who you are watching
this video but God's speaking to you
right now you didn't watch it by
accident
this is not merely to selva to settle a
little aligned intellectual curiosity
about Hell God's speaking to you to get
on your knees right now and give your
life to Christ the Bible says for God so
loved the world that whosoever believeth
in him should not perish God so loved
the world that He gave His only begotten
Son that whosoever believeth in him
should not perish but have eternal life
God doesn't want you to perish to be
burned to ashes to be consumed and smoke
and gone he wants you to have eternal
life we'll reach out to him right now by
faith what does our text say for God so
loved the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever whosoever
means you wherever you are it means you
your sins can be forgiven your guilt can
be gone you can be saved in God's
kingdom for
ever and ever and effort you can live
with him through all eternity why not
bow your head and pray with me right now
and give your life fully to him father
in heaven we open our hearts to Jesus
right now you have provided salvation
for us you are reaching out to save us
right now there's somebody watching this
video that your heart is gonna touch
their life has been going in a different
direction and they sense the love of God
they sense that you want to save them
they sense that their sins can be
forgiven they sense that they do not
want to burn in hell and be consumed and
gone to ashes forever they want to live
forever the abundant life they were
created right now I pray for that person
right now may they be touched by your
spirit right now fill them with your
love and grace save them in your kingdom
forgive their sins and when you come
again
may they look up and say this is our God
we've waited for him and he'll save us
thank you Lord that you've said that if
we come to you you'll never cast us out
I know you're saving men and women right
now by your grace in Christ's name Amen
I'd really like to keep in touch with
you and share with you more of the
videos we're doing I hope you've enjoyed
the video today and go ahead and
subscribe would love to partner with you
in your spiritual journey as you
subscribe you can also push that little
bell button and we'll give you further
notification of other videos that we're
producing we're really anxious to answer
questions you might have this subject
may have stimulated questions on your
behalf and feel free to ask them we
didn't answer every single question in
the video and so if you have comments or
questions feel free to ask those
questions you can do that by going to
hopelives365.com/questions
Let me give you
that again it's hopelives365.com/questions
I'll be looking
forward to your questions
you